good morning Hank it's dirt what what is
today went it's Wednesday January 9th
10th 10th boy I'm out of it
hi girls who are being used as objects
to sell other objects sorry about the
patriarchal oppression good luck selling
dodge caravans it was inspired by your
video blog yesterday to calculate my own
carbon footprint so I'm gonna go to BP
calm and do it and then it's gonna be
pretty boring so I'm gonna speed up the
tape idiot
Hank I produce 16 tons of carbon a year
that is lower than the United States
average of eighteen point five eight but
it's still really bad 16 tons of carbon
would fill three Olympic sized swimming
pools global warming solution idea what
if we took a lot of Olympic sized
swimming pools and we filled them with
carbon and we shot them into space
wouldn't that work can you shoot an
Olympic sized swimming pool into space
is there a way to condense the carbon
dioxide into swimming pool sized shapes
anyway I think this could work I don't
understand why no one thought of it
before I just read on the internet that
it only cost $6 per ton to get rid of
your carbon footprint ah that means that
it's only gonna cost me like I'm not
very good at math hold on a minute call
Daniel I don't know he's not answering
maybe he's doing real math
Hey how's it going okay's 21 - 814 oh
this is one of those this is one of
those like abstract math jokes it's
funny you should say that because I'm
actually recording this on the video
blog right now because I have a question
for you what sixteen times six it's 96
do you see how fast he did that he
doesn't have a calculator 96 96 dollars
a year that's what it would cost to
offset my carbon consumption my carbon
production or whatever if I pay Al Gore
96 dollars I will not have any global
warming attached to my name I think you
can pay him directly I think you just
write him a check and he just takes care
of it he does he eats the carbon that's
exactly right that's how he does it he
eats the carbon and then when he poops
it out it's actually political gold